[Musique]
cette semaine après deux ans de travaux
la nouvelle a dû marcher des
clayes-sous-bois a ouvert la quarantaine
de commerçants ont retrouvé ses clients
toujours pas de réouverture en vue pour
les salles de spectacle mais la création
continue sur saint quentin en yvelines
la mission d'un sa compagne la compagnie
mémé banjo pour une représentation au
visage et en mai à versailles grand parc
le début de l'année rime avec
originalité pour le ramassage des sapins
de noël
l'agglomération a choisi de le faire en
calèche elle les salles de sport sont
encore à l'arrêt certains professionnels
se sont rassemblés devant l'assemblée
nationale cette semaine depuis le mois
de décembre 8 médiateurs et des agents
de proximité sillonnent les différents
quartiers de la verrière pour échanger
avec les habitants
leur objectif l'insertion sociale et
tranquillité publique
elle était députée européenne de la
circonscription ile de france 2 99 à
marielle de sarnez est décédé mercredi
13 janvier elle souffrait d'une leucémie
le groupe au losange lance arnaud
lucioles usine historique de flins sera
transformée en établissement spécialisé
dans l'économie circulaire avec des
services dédiés aux véhicules
électriques et à l'énergie
le technocentre à guyancourt travaillera
sur la connectivité du véhicule avec
d'autres entreprises installées dans les
yvelines
[Musique]
pas